depuis deux semaines on observe de
nombreuses images de policiers jetant
leurs menottes en signe de protestation
et mécontentement envers leurs ministres
ainsi que des mobilisations souvent
nocturnes
le climat est particulièrement tendue
entre les affaires de racisme devient
messageries et réseaux sociaux et celle
de violences policières dans les
yvelines 150 fonctionnaires de police se
sont réunies lundi devant le
commissariat de versailles
je viens le cam secrétaire général
régional des yvelines deux syndicats de
police alliance et en communication avec
nous bonjour bonjour alors vous étiez
lundi avec vos collègues que souhaitiez
vous dénoncez tout d'abord le ras-le-bol
c'était un cri lundi un véritable
ras-le-bol suite aux propos tenus par
notre ministre un qui a qui a carrément
lâché notre profession a lâché mes
collègues et lundi on voulait justement
montrer notre mécontentement et notre
ras-le-bol
à travers cette cette opération se jeter
de menottes devant le commissariat de
versailles à vous demander même le
départ du ministre qui streiff
christophe casanave de steam et qu'il
gère mal la situation à tout à fait il a
lâché littéralement la profession notre
secrétariat général et notre secrétaire
général alliance police nationale
demandent à rencontrer le président de
la république pour justement évoqué le
malaise de la profession et faire part
notamment de toutes nos revendications
parce que on a un cahier de
revendications importants et en
justement j'avais demandé si vous aviez
eu des réponses depuis la manifestation
de lundi des retours alors nous avons
obtenu des rendez vous auprès du dgpn il
ya deux rendez vous de prévu le 30 juin
et le 3 juillet et je sais que nous
sommes toujours en attente de rencontrer
le président de la république
alors vous me disiez vous aviez beaucoup
de revendications quelle est la
situation actuelle dans la police il ya
un grand malaise vous pouvez vous en
rendre compte lundi en plus en plus de
mes collègues de la sécurité publique on
pouvait les voir aussi mes collègues de
la police judiciaire qui sont joints à
nous ce qui est plutôt rare et qui
montre qu'il ya un vrai ras-le-bol
généralisé dans la profession il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de revendications qui
restent sans réponse
et justement on souhaiterait faire le
point avec le défi
pn notamment sur la réforme du
management des conditions de travail les
conditions du travailleur de nuit le
manque d'effectif le manque de moyens
qui est criant et notamment dans les
yvelines et comment vous l'expliquez ce
malaise
justement si vous voulez il ya eu
beaucoup de réformes de fait on a fait
beaucoup d'économies dans la profession
en plus d'être lâché par notre ministre
de l'intérieur on peut parler d'un d'un
laxisme judiciaire qui crée un sentiment
d'impunité parmi les délinquants et le
département a été en froid durant le
confinement à plusieurs semaines de
violences urbaines et d' acte très
violent on le voit encore un dimanche
dernier dimanche soir dernier à houilles
un an des règlements de comptes entre
bandes à coups de machette
donc il faut savoir que le département
est un département malheureusement trop
violent et le ministère de l'intérieur
fait des économies d'effectifs alors
qu'ils devraient au contraire en
injecter en injecter plus alors parmi
les annonces de christophe castaner il
ya plusieurs mesures comme la fin de la
technique dite de l'étranglement vous
l'avez dit avec le taser comme
alternative la suspension systématique
pour chaque soupçons d'actes racistes
avérés et encore une réforme de l'igpn
vous avez parlé de l'igpn cette réforme
est ce qu'elle serait la clé finalement
pour établir une forme de confiance
entre police citoyens même vous avec
votre hiérarchie
si vous voulez nous les l'igpn nous mes
collègues
voilà quand ils sont amenés à y aller
s'ils présentent un voile à ccc des
actes de procédure on va dire pas
habituel et nous on n'est pas sur cette
amende à nous si vous voulez quand on
entend le ministre de l'intérieur parce
parler de soude sont avérées présumés
enfin c'est quelque chose de ridicule y
stigmatise de l'ensemble de la
profession il faut savoir que les
fonctionnaires de police font partie de
la catégorie des fonctionnaires les plus
sanctionnées déjà en france et je peux
vous dire que malheureusement au moindre
écart
justement les les sanctions tombent nous
comme en 2019 qui montrent que le nombre
d' enquête a augmenté mais que le nombre
sur un thème diminué oui alors ça s'ils
voulaient nous sur le sur le département
on est loin d'un peu tout ça il faut
savoir que nous ce que l'on demande dans
un premier temps c'est d'eux que mes
collègues et cette présomption
d'innocence parce que quand on entend le
ministre parlait on a l'impression que
mes collègues sont systématiquement
coupable et ne peuvent pas de bénéficier
cette présomption d'innocence après les
et enquêtes sont diligentées par l'igpn
ou même des fois par la direction
départementale et je peux vous dire que
quand mes collègues sont mises en cause
ils sont lourdement sanctionnés
malheureusement il n'y a pas de
passe-droit pour notre profession
au contraire on est une profession très
surveillé très sanctionnés et justement
à travers les propos aussi de monsieur
castanet on a l'impression d'une
stigmatisation de l'ensemble de la
profession qui est pas acquis à la
normale pour conclure cet entretien est
ce que vous prévoyez d'autres
mobilisations williams
alors pour l'instant effectivement il
hier soit on a eu un rassemblement du
côté de sartrouville donc pour l'instant
la colère ne retombe pas parce qu'on n'a
pas d' annonce encore vraiment concrètes
et mes collègues attendent beaucoup
parce qu'il ya un vrai ras-le-bol et
notamment dans les yvelines
parce qu'il faut savoir que mes
collègues ont été durement touchés et
mobiliser également durant la période du
coc vie de 19 coups ils ont été en
première ligne pour comment faire gérer
la le confinement et si vous voulez mes
collègues attendent beaucoup
et s'il faut continuer à mobiliser nous
sommes merci je viens le quément d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
je le rappelle vous êtes secrétaire
régional des yvelines du syndicat de
police alliance